[Musique]
le village de corail à saint-gilles
propose un habitat un solide depuis 2015
une cabane forestière réalisés avec des
matériaux pays comme le bois de goyavier
il à vincent alexandre et leurs familles
sous venus y passer leurs vacances ainsi
que les fêtes de fin d'année il a décidé
de passer et tout le monde est fait trop
sur nous jusqu'à d'autres gens qui vont
nous rejoindre on serait un voeu
personnes donc c'était plus facile de
louer ici et d'avoir accès à la plage
tout on put on s'assied peste cette
famille de dionysiens est ravi de son
séjour des prestations et du standing
proposés et bien c'est propre c'est
impeccable franchement dans la
prestation et pour tous les jours et
arrosez être en vacances dans un cas
comme celui-là c'est toujours assez
frais exceptionnels
on a l'impression de ne plus faire
partie vraiment du village puisque les
roches vraiment quand on en rencontre
n'a eu l'occasion de tous loués on a
l'impression que c'est vraiment chez
nous donc c'est vraiment très agréable
et ça c'est très cosy quoi un logement
agréable et spacieux que la famille
s'est approprié puisqu'il où cette
cabane forestière pour la cinquième fois
alors ici vous avez de la cuisine
ouverte donc vraiment complet on a tout
pour passer un séjour sans aucun
problème on se fait nous mêmes nos
petits plats une des chambres assez
spacieuse quand même la salle de bain
ainsi que les toilettes un deuxième
champ de la laitages équipés d'une télé
d'un grandi vous avez quand même une
grande terrasse avec la vue sur la
piscine et surtout le village et la
valeur ajoutée du lieu
le jacuzzi raconte pas ça me super six
jours donc je crois bien un concept qui
séduit de nombreux vacanciers le
département souhaite développer cette
structure un peu partout sur l'île
[Musique]